my name is Rafa I'm a little scientist
in Paris based company in France so we
mostly do computer vision so I've been
for the past year caris and tensorflow
contributor and I've built EF explain
because there was like no specific
libraries to for and for
interpretability and i wanted like to be
accessible to most most users so what is
interpretability so when you start for
example if you load iris datasets and
you want to Train linear regression on
it you can like easily find what's are
your parameters and how the model behave
compared to the data set what are the
important features and it's kind of a
white box because you can really
understand and take a deep look at what
what is happening what are the features
that are important there are limited
numbers of parameters so you can really
understand what the model is doing and
explain its decision but the problem is
that when it comes to more large
networks with millions of parameters how
do you do that how you know you have
some multiple convolutional filters
which applies to the whole image how can
you know which which activations are the
most important for your output decision
how do you do you you just explain okay
my my deep learning models is predicting
it's a cat
what in the image is actually what's
important predict the cat is is it
really focusing on the cat and not on
some bias in the rest of the image so
that's what interpretability is it's
mostly giving an input giving an
explanation on what is important for the
model to take the decision so basically
it's mostly for computer
science maps which means you visualize
on the input what's important for for
the decision so the more important zone
the color map will like translate this
phenomena and you will just have some
out regions in in yellow and cold
regions in in blue so before going in I
will take a bit about ten to flee to
really easy because and mostly all focus
on the training parts because it will
help you understand and make sure you
are at least for the rest of the
presentations so the main change is that
Karis has been the major API for
tensorflow
you have three different levels
depending on what are your needs so it
goes from the second row bi which helps
build linear models where the output of
the previous layer will be passed as the
input of the next one there is this
functional API which is a little more
complex but which helps you to build
normally you know nonlinear models for
example if you are if you have some
residual connections and then there is
these sub classing api which is like a
lot like pi torch implementation where
you can define a class define all the
variables layers you have in it and then
apply the logic as as you want in in the
forward pass okay so we'll talk about
the first two ABI and the training
process in these in those IP is so when
you start a layer so the first step is
to load the sample data so you just have
some tensors you build you build a model
by stacking linearly in a list
your your layers so for example here we
have just about average pooling and then
a dance layer and you specifies the
input shape to the first layers so for
example here we have images of 28 by 28
and 3 3 channels and we we just want you
to take a binary decision on it then you
just compile it with specifying a loss
and an optimizer eventually you you can
define some metrics you want you to get
during the training process and then you
can fit it on your data to to train the
model so the output this kind of graph
you create of models it's in the top
right corner it's purely linear graphs
so the output of first layer is input to
the second layer and you can't have more
sub two architectures and that with this
a vehicle so there is this functional
API that allows us to go with different
architectures for example you know to
implement residual connections so you
you still have the same the same idea of
you load the data and then you define
your model and the differential of your
model is you take an input you specify
the input and you apply all the layers
to two variables and you take the output
you take in in in other variables so you
can play and specify the inputs to a
specific layer so for example here we we
save the inputs in an input variable so
we can pass it to the add layer later
and create the residual connections so
it allows in most case I've seen for
prediction simple models it's enough to
to build most models if you're not
building some kind of specific
penalization regulations it's clearly
enough for you to get started and then
you have you still have sis compiled and
fitting which remains the same between
the api's okay so now the other point I
wanted to show you is how you can get
gradients with the attentively to
release so in the 1.14 version for
example you had to to obtain those
gradients
you have to just get the data define
some placeholders define also all the
graph you want to run and you have this
cost function that you pass inside a GF
session so basically the computation of
those variables were painful to have you
had to create sessions you have to to
think about scope names does
initialization of variables
it's was pretty painful to debug because
it was it was not executing eagerly so
you couldn't access variable values at
runtime so now say first they fixed a
bit this behavior by enabling Z eager
execution so now when you you define
your model and you apply it to two
specific input x and y you can have
access directly to those values so if
you see we use a gradient type object
which has been introduced in this
version and what it does it's it records
all operations that are done and it
helps to get the gradients on the
operations that have been performed
during this during the contacts so
you run all the necessary operations
inside this context object and then the
tape that gradient methods contains all
the gradients you can have on this graph
and then you can apply it to the model
parameters with the optimizer apply
gradients methods
okay so that was a pretty subset of what
has changed in terms of flow - there is
a lot more to discover around eager
execution autograft if that function
there are also a whole ecosystem of
libraries they've built for mobile
mobile devices for for prediction use
for scaling so I've put in some
additional resources this is not
exhaustive you can you can clearly find
a lot of stuff good stuff on the doesn't
flow website so I encourage you to visit
it
so now I'm gonna talk more on
interpretability and before we get
started and drive into some methods that
can be a bit like confusing and complex
and what I wanted to present is GF
explain which is a library that compiles
a lot of those methods with a simple API
so you can basically use it every day
without thinking about okay I have to
build something really complex on my
model and I don't want to the idea is
basically to make the user make the user
able to run without any effort some
interpretive methods so the important
thing was to like focus on certain
surfer workflow so one one major thing
is being able to visualize during
training directly intense about what
what are the output
science maps so here you can see that we
have run some methods on the model
during training and during training we
can monitor if there are how the model
is is doing on the validation set and we
can like directly come from some methods
between them see what are the outputs if
there are some biases happy years so for
now there is a seven the slide is not up
to date seven methods that are available
so you can directly compare methods
the idea is to the problem of
interpretability is that there is no
official metrics to to say okay this one
is better than this one a lot of
research papers are just okay say they
give the methods to some users and get
some feedback on it so my advice on this
is do not trust one method particularly
and use different methods at the same
time to come from them to understand if
they if they have the same opinion on
the input if they produce a similar
saliency map or if they just are in
going in the opposite directions so you
you can just have some different judges
on on what the input is okay so how to
use TF explained so it's - - way to do
it the first one is let's say you have
this model which is already pre framed
for example the VG gives 16 and you want
to see how it performs so you want to
check run some methods on some given
inputs and checks that the input through
science maps for this input with is kind
of logical so you load the model and the
variation data you you just instantiate
as methods you want use you want to use
and then you have
for all all methods implemented in Jeff
explained you have this dot explained
method entry points which is the same
which always takes the validation data
and model to two to observe and
eventually depending on the methods some
additional parameters you can you can
tune and then you it directly saves the
output of the of the algorithm as a PNG
format so you can observe directly the
the color as a syringe Maps inside your
your computer the other way to do this
is I was hire as I was explaining
earlier you want to monitor during
training what is happening so basically
you want to have a callback that after
each epoch is running some methods and
you want to visualize during training
how the output of these methods are are
going so what you do is take a subset
for a given let's say you're given class
and then you want to in to you want to
call a specific callback each method
implemented in the library as its
corresponding go back so you can just
okay let's say I want to use these
methods okay so I'll take its
corresponding callback and pass it to
the feet callbacks arguments so now when
the fit is running it directly saves see
the output as a transport format and you
can just run them to board and see what
happens so we
we've released as a package in August so
you can check it song bye-bye
it's called chief explained and now I'll
just dive into some more some methods
implemented in it so you can just have
some like have some notions of what
interpretive methods are because it's
not only visualize the activations of
convolutions there are more to that
because visualizing activation helps to
identify if kernels are kind of useless
or are doing like something weird with
input but it doesn't really give
feedback on its like its importance of
the features so the first one we'll
explore is called occlusion sensitivity
and the objective is to hide some parts
of the image successively and just see
there is a drop in confidence on the
output because what what you want to say
is okay if I hide some part of the image
like that makes a significant drop in
the confidence that must be because this
particular part of the image must be
important to the decision and must be
important to the model to take its
decision
so you just hide successively and build
a heat map corresponding to the
confidence
I'll put it for this patched image so
basically what you want is just to
create the patched image so you apply
some gray patch over a certain region
and for each patch or your predict with
your model and take the target
confidence of the predictions and then
you can create back a heat map with the
where you take one minus the confidence
because if there is a drop you want to
be you want it to be some
positive on the heatmap so the large
will to drop the the more the bigger on
the hitman
so this methods as some problems because
it's like pretty inefficient you have to
to run multiple predictions you want to
maybe make it make the patch size
variable because sometimes it's going to
be small features sometimes it's going
to be a big one so you can have a really
precise way to say okay is this part of
the image is important and you you have
to like merge some multiple outputs
multiple saliency maps with different
patch sizes to build something you can
really trust and it's kind of
computationally expensive so people
started to say okay we're on deep nets
everything is about gradients they must
have some some kind of information on
what are good features and bad features
on the map on the input so what if we
just look at the gradients so what if we
just look at what makes an input image a
better cat for example there are some
regions in the image that are already
like just come in discriminative to be a
cat and the idea is that if these those
parts are really important gradients
will be larger than than other other for
example the wall behind the cat so what
you get updates are on the output is a
gray gray scale map and the idea is like
we're well its whiter Z it means the
features are more important to the
networks and where the zones are are
gray so the problem with that is
that okay we'll just explore how to do
it so you load your your sample sample
image you load your model and you you
load what is the expected output you
want so for for us we just want it to be
a gap so we would create a one-up vector
and the loss will be the difference
between the predictions and the actual
one how to encode it cat and note that
here we we added a tape that watch on
the inputs because we want the gradients
on the input and not on the model so
when you you run you run this you just
get the gradients inside that they take
the gradient object and it's just simply
the output Maps you want C output
saliency maps you want to visualize so
this has some major issues because it's
pretty open to interpretations for
example if we see the the science e maps
for the kite class when we predict a cat
it has some interesting features of a
Ricard for example the nose the years if
you if you just like show the kite
gradients to someone it will say okay
that explains a lot on the predictions
but the problem is that it's not exactly
what is relevant it should be the cat
should shouldn't have beer on the
gradients for the kite class so this has
raised some some interest in how we
check that an interpretive eating method
is is like relevant is producing good
examples and it is really explaining
what the model is doing and rather than
just saying nonsense so
the first one is okay you you have this
model and basically if you change some
parameters in it the output saliency map
should should change too and the more
you randomize some parameters the more
the saliency maps would should do
nonsense and that's because if we really
are observing the model and if you
really random eyes a lot of parodies in
it is should the model ssin able be able
to predict anymore that it's a cat so
the explanation map for zakat shouldn't
shouldn't appear as it was at the
beginning and what's kind of warning in
in this parameters randomization is that
some methods are actually kind of the
same over the randomizations so even
with high high proportion of randomized
parameters we we can see that the hit
map the sciency maps stays the same and
that's because there's a lot of methods
that depends on the input to provide an
explanations so what we see is that
there is a lot more a lot more influence
from the input then from the model
itself on the output map and that that's
why it's produce a constant constant
output even if the model is completely
nonsense okay see the other check is
training a model with randomized
randomized data we want to make sure
that if we really if the model is really
explaining a class if we randomized the
label during training the the output map
shouldn't learn something as the model
shouldn't learn
something and it's not just switching
label labels between them is really
randomizing some some levels inside the
data set so basically if we randomized a
high proportion of labels the models
should will learn some noise over the
data so it shouldn't produce a science
map that is corresponding to the one
with true levels labels so to conclude
we will explore one last method which is
called grad camp which is based on the
activation maps of the last layer of the
network so you take the last filters of
your network before the dense layers
which activates a different region and
the idea is that those filters are the
features to the dance air so you you get
you will get the decision of the dense
layer based on those features so if we
can manage to ponder rate those features
to to see what's the weight for each
filter we can we can induce like the the
region of the image that is important to
the decision so what we do to to weight
those filters is we take the gradients
over over those and we'll gonna
specially average the gradients because
if the gradients are high of a high
value for a given filter it means it has
more waste or the final decision
so especially if ratings is easy
gradients help us build a final column
column app by weighting on the filters
so you take filter one you take
gradients for filter one towards the
final decision is the gradients with
high value or low value
and depending on that you you all had
those features with the corresponding
weights okay if we look at the
implementations use you want to build a
sub graph that outputs both the last
convolutional layer and the output so
when you run the predictions you will
get the output of the convolutions and
the output of the layer you will compute
the loss which is maximizing the
prediction prediction score for the
zakat and then you just do this
especially averaging and do the weight
average of the filters with respect to
the weights of the gradients and and
that's it and that's how you you get an
output map which is the size of the last
convolutional output so for example for
vgg is going to be 14 by 14 but has the
the convolutions are taking spatially
zones you can deconstruct your 14 by 14
choose your regional image size and the
output for this in what why it's I
consider it to be like one of the best
options right now it's that it's pretty
much effective because you do not have
to back propagate to all the old
inaudible you only have to back pro-gay
propagate to the last convolutions and
you have some outputs that really
respects this label label check which
means that when you observe the output
for the cat it really is different from
the chi class and what we observe is
that even for the kite one the cat
becomes a really cool
which means it identifies that features
are not at all relevant to the kite and
say they just made confidence drop for
this gasps okay so my advice on this is
really learn to you you have now so you
have now chief explained which helps use
interpreter be methods my advice is when
you use some it's a nice step towards
understanding neural networks but please
don't use only one because interpreter B
methods are either high like
subjectivity in them you want to be able
to compare methods between them to make
sure that they are they all agree on the
decision and you don't want to just
trust one methods blind thank you and if
there are some questions we'll be happy
to answer it
okay thank you